hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play to neveress link so I
discovered it was pronounced I am
without a lantern I am without it is
dark in this place very very dark
forever a duck and I didn't see it's
like I don't know what the deal is with
I've never had people like try to keep
away always this a big door
I've never people keep away like for
this long I mean if you're wondering why
you can't see anything
I can't see anything either this is just
how dark it is there's nothing to see
anyway so okay that's the big door there
was another door over there
there's no Lantern hello oh you're
mouthing ooh
job I jump over Hugh Oh can't sink isn't
can't see
seriously they must have like the uber
darkness activated because this is
ridiculous
I don't even have anything I don't have
anything I have no
skull two points
oh yeah oh three points yeah oh yeah
okay nothing in there still can't see
no please lantern me please man please
sir I have a lantern
hi I am in darkness I would totally miss
anything you put in front of my face I
would miss it by a lot okay that's it
I'm turning up again I'm turning up the
game I have to I just I gotta I can't
see anything otherwise but I miss oh
dude it good good
I love you in there oh how many listen
can we look back into team do dark doo
doo ooh yeah
okay okay okay so there's nothing in
these rumors
okay there's nothing in those rooms
nothing in these rooms nothing of value
no lantern I miss this I would have
hidden one of these things I've never
seen these before have I I don't know I
don't think so oh just piles of bones
nothing in here
nothing of value sorry buddy mr. Gillman
okay so and this is Haven again I would
totally miss that because I couldn't see
a damn thing
okay Tom this is the big door oh I don't
even what do I do
was that supposed to kill me we get up
don't we get up let me out let me out
let me out let me out I mean let me out
get me out let me out let me out let me
out let me out let me out let me out
buddy
lemmya anything I don't see oh please
something here can't see what is this I
can't even tell I I can't even see what
it is it's like some sort of platform or
something I don't know is there like a
ladder oh there's a letter okay I am but
was there something down here that I was
supposed to get it was that just troll
pit that I couldn't see cuz it's so
friggin dark
doo-doo-doo-doo dead okay so anyway shut
up now see no one likes you you have no
friends
alright so this is a little better I can
actually see so hopefully all I won't
miss anything coming by maybe I had like
the reason oh I almost choked on my own
spit
maybe the reason that I could see like
in regular amnesia and other custom
stories because this is like a whole new
main game I had to reset a lot of the
options for this so maybe like my gamma
setting got dropped down that's why it
seems so dark either way it's still dark
but at least I can navigate
man I I don't even know how you can play
you need you on such darkness
they'd be like impossible to find
everything you need and tourneys
darkness I'm not free was it another
body well that's an amnesia grunt grunt
torso that's uh yeah yeah what's he
doing here probably eaten by the new
monsters okay nothing over here this is
just a cave-in right right right right
no Dan no lantern okay nothing here
nothing here nothing here uh-huh
I don't have anything to use on it got
plenty of oil but nothing to use it on
please i want lantern i want to let oh
oh where was this the side passage that
I totally missed oh oh how can I only be
six minutes in Oh
nothing troll troll chest uh hammer mm
anybody ooh ah now that's a different
length intersting and a switch I came in
open that chest winder there this goes
to a lever it goes to something now the
answer is what and where oh well by the
door of course by the door
sorry sledge II left weight on you for
the next round and I can pop up ah there
it is
just like that clunk OH
Thank You Leonard thank you for being
there for me
now do I I'm actually concerned because
I haven't come across from another one
of those save things so I wonder if it's
actually Auto saving her if it's really
doing anything for me oh it's so nice to
be able to see also nice what's in here
I scared I got my lantern oh no oh [ __ ]
Oh get it EDD piggy piggy piggy oink
like
mmm I don't like this cuz your story
sure
finally finally my friend come back to
me
ah key and key machine room key and the
dungeon key I thought I was already in
the dungeon okay anyway cover you never
won leave my side again till I throw you
at the monsters and run away in fear
okay let's see dungeon
nope not ever
okay why I need a key that was right in
the room next to it I don't know I'm
gonna ask questions
oh this is oh this is um this is another
area ah this is the way back can I use
this I don't get this isn't so I got to
go find the machine room there wasn't
any other door this is in one side I
don't think there was another door but
let me check there my friend think so I
don't think so but there might been no
no no no no no no that was it that was
it chair come with me you protect me
from the monster
I'm gonna be conservative about my
lantern this I don't know when they're
gonna give me more oil well they already
have given me oil that night I don't
trust these dudes I don't trust them we
weren't you there
oh I mannequin a mannequin so much hate
him oh oh oh okay I'm okay
ah levers no instructions well throw
them around willy-nilly willy-nilly
winner I guess I I guess I got it maybe
that open the big door uh there I don't
know
I'll get turned around into place a lot
okay so did that it did oh yeah oh and
there's a safe point okay where's that
yumping and these safe boys are far
apart like I'm not gonna be able to stop
light
oh that's Purdy
that's actually really pretty okay so
anyway not much air come back okay
anybody story
I love sores cuz everything good happens
in storage okay
anyway any minute now
yeah this a closer look really far away
it's kind of inconvenient
hello stairs hello hello hello box
anything behind nope I can pound you a
new shoe good a blue shoe alright
anything up here bhauja found it honey
honey got dearer laudanum boy oh there's
balcony up there okay anyway I can't get
it or maybe I can maybe I need to stack
boxes up no there's no entry way up
there anyway or is there a spectral man
that would take forever to build things
up like that let me go exploring
otherwise I could if I wanted to but I
don't feel like it right now
who's there huh oh this is up here
anyway see I would have just wasted my
time if I had tried here I know that was
it but it's just a loop
it's a loopy loop oh no ice mesh hello
tinderbox can you please get some light
here
that's not much light hey you hey you
dinner bucks nice coat ooh
Oh
Oh
there's someone out there but it'll be
the only loo little illa season
oh that's the moose man didn't sound
like the Moose man at first
I like the new music
okay I think it's clear what uh how was
that maybe it was like it didn't sound
like him effort maybe that was a new
monster and they just kind of combined
voices thank for the nerdy boxes and
urban tinderboxes chain oh oh I don't
like this I don't like this
okay don't need to go back what you see
to easter-egg key will you find the door
come on
it's probably in that room with all the
stacks I am supposed to stack up to
something
say perfect Oh oh my goodness thank you
thank you Oh perfect okay I'm all out of
time for this episode so thank you all
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next part
bye bye